[Música]
Bienvenidos a directo top 27 el espacio
en el que les contamos lo más relevante
de todo lo que ha sucedido en la Cumbre
climática de la ONU que se realiza en
Egipto el sector de la energía que
incluye la electricidad la calefacción y
la refrigeración y el transporte es
responsable de dos tercios de las
emisiones contaminantes que aceleran el
calentamiento global y la crisis
climática de estas más de un tercio
provienen de la generación eléctrica la
Cumbre climática en Egipto llega en un
momento de crisis energética derivada de
la guerra en Ucrania y los recortes de
gas impulsados por Rusia esto ha hecho
que se disparen los precios de la
energía producida con combustibles
fósiles como el petróleo o el gas y por
otro lado han vuelto a inclinar la
balanza de algunos países europeos hacia
la energía nuclear Marina Colorado una
de nuestras enviadas especiales a la
cop27 nos amplía
en la agenda del día de hoy Estaba la
energía y en directo con 27 hemos
querido centrarnos en la energía nuclear
y hablar tanto con sus Defensores como
con sus detractores para ello me
acompaña Bianca carpinelli ella es
asesoral del departamento de energía
nuclear de la del organismo
internacional de energía atómica Gracias
por estar con France 24 quería
preguntarle cuál es el papel que
desempeña la energía nuclear en la lucha
contra el cambio climático la energía
nuclear que provee el 10% de la
electricidad mundial es una energía
limpia y de base limpia porque no emite
gases de efecto invernadero durante su
operación y de base porque la energía
nuclear opera 24/7 sin importar el sol
la lluvia el viento etcétera Durante los
últimos 50 años se estima que el uso de
la energía nuclear evitó que se
emitieran a la atmósfera entre 70 y 78
gigatones de dióxido de carbono la
agencia de energía internacional de
energía de la ocde estima que para
mediados de este siglo la energía
nuclear va a tener que más que
duplicarse para llegar a los objetivos
climáticos
lo que dice esta agencia es muy claro
sin el uso de energía nuclear la
transición energética va a ser más
difícil más larga y Más costosa sin
embargo cuando pensamos en energía
nuclear todos nos acordamos de desastres
accidentes como Chernobyl fukushima
ustedes defienden que la energía nuclear
es confiable la energía nuclear es una
energía confiable porque opera 24 horas
al día 7 días a la semana sin importar
los los las condiciones climáticas y
nonstop
Asimismo con la urgencia climática que
estamos viviendo hoy y la crisis
energética que se está sintiendo sobre
todo en Europa Es indispensable
diversificar la matriz energética en ese
sentido las energías renovables y la
energía nuclear van muy bien juntas
porque porque al ser inintemitente la
energía nuclear le provee energía de
base a una matriz energética
diversificada que incluye energía
nuclear y energías renovables y
finalmente y muy brevemente Cuál es lo
que esperan de esta cop27 en cuanto
energía nuclear bueno Esta es la primera
vez que la energía nuclear tiene una
presencia física en la 27 en la zona
azul de la con 27 tenemos un pabellón
que se llama iTunes al cual todos los
que están acá son Bienvenidos a venir
tenemos paneles y eventos de diversos
temas que abarcan a la energía nuclear y
al rol de la energía nuclear tanto en la
mitigación de cambio climático como a la
adaptación del cambio climático que es
otro mundo también que la energía
nuclear abarca Muchísimas gracias Bianca
y como lo mencioné anteriormente no todo
el mundo defiende los beneficios de la
energía nuclear
la energía nuclear es demasiado cara por
el dinero que cuesta tanto su
instalación como su mantenimiento
demasiado contaminante por esos
toneladas de residuos que generan la
extracción del uranio sobre todo
demasiado peligrosa por esos cientos de
miles de toneladas de residuos
radiactivos que duran durante miles de
años sobre los cuales no tenemos ninguna
respuesta de cómo almacenarlos sin que
contamine a las personas que viven cerca
el discurso nuclear es profundamente
falso por varias razones primero porque
Europa dependen al menos un 40% de las
reservas de uranio ruso segundo porque
nadie está planteando en nuevas
centrales nucleares debido a los
elevados costes que tiene y tercero
porque las nuclear respecto a las
energías renovables contaminan entre 6 y
15 veces más en el clima que la
renovables a las que sustituyen como ven
posturas contrarias pero que conviven en
esta con 27 en charmel say con esto
terminamos directo con 27 por hoy
volvemos con ustedes en Bogotá
a nuestras enviadas especiales en
charmershare Les agradecemos sus
interesantes reportes y a ustedes
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Francia 24 y France
24.com
[Música]